eine mikrobe zersetzt den kunststoff in
den weltmeeren die lösung für das große
plastik müll problem jetzt in klicks uns
ein sandwich forscher vom kyoto
institute of technology haben einen
mikroben stamm entdeckt der die
biologisch nicht abbaubar eigentlich
nicht abbaubaren plastikabfälle wie pc
zu ersetzen kann
der stamm idiom ellers kann jens greift
die abfälle mit hilfe des enzyms plaza
an und spaltet den kunststoff in
ethylenglykol und terrestar säure auf
italien glykol ist der einfachste zwei
wertige alkohol tiefenthal säure ist
einen wasser schwer aber nicht ganz
unlösliche organisch chemische
verbindung zitat der pt film wurde stark
beschädigt und war nach sechs wochen bei
30 grad fast komplett abgebaut
die bakterien zersetzen die ptv
oberfläche in einer rate von 0 13
milligramm pro quadratzentimeter und tag
75 prozent des kohlenstoffs aus dem pc
wurde zu co2 umgesetzt so die forscher
wie die experten weiter berichteten
könne in alaska aces ausschließlich vom
pc leben entdeckt wurden die mikroben
bei der untersuchung von pt abfällen und
den darauf befindlichen bakterienstämmen
die mikrobe könne also die lösung eines
risiken und sehr bedrohlichen problem
seien die gewinnbringende nutzung der
mikrobe ist aber noch nicht alles das pt
wurde erst im jahr 1941 entwickelt
ideeller es kann jens es habe also eine
rasante leistung in ihrer eigenen
evolution verbracht innerhalb dieser
kurzen zeit solche effektive enzyme zu
entwickeln ist nämlich sehr sehr
ungewöhnlich und anzeichen dass die
wissenschaft evolutionsprozess zum teil
unterschätzt unsere eigene also die
evolution des menschen lässt bei dem
plastik problem etwas zu wünschen übrig
wir haben uns das problem selbst
geschaffen ohne eine eigene lösung parat
zu haben
die menschheit produziert jedes jahr
rund 300 millionen tonnen plastikabfall
ein großer teil des kunststoffs gelangt
in die ozeane und 70 prozent davon
sinken dann in tiefere wasserschichten
ab dieser müll enthält rund 50 millionen
ec und wenn das ab sinkt dann ist es nur
schwer erreichbar mit der zeit werden
die plastikteile immer weiter
zerkleinert und verteilen sich im wasser
so gelangt das plastik in die nahe
als kette und tiere nehmen die teilchen
auf zwei teilchen plankton kommt im
mittelmeer zum beispiel ein teilchen
plastik und durch den verzehr von fisch
oder meeresfrüchten gelangen sie auch
wieder in den menschlichen körper
gefährlich sind dabei unter anderem auch
die weichmacher die in plastik enthalten
sind viele weichmacher gelten als bio
akkumulieren das bedeutet dass sie sich
in großen mengen in organismen ansammeln
können mittlerweile können diese stoffe
selbst bei kleinkindern im blut und im
gewebe nachgewiesen werden außerdem
ziehen die plastik partikel gefährliche
chemikalien an die ebenfalls von den
tieren aufgenommen werden die
nahrungskette wird somit zunehmend
vergiftet und das passiert schon sehr
lange in den selbst entlegensten orten
der welt der kunststoffabfall ist schon
bis in die hohen breiten der arktis
vorgedrungen zu dieser erkenntnis
gelangte dr melanie bergmann im jahr
2012 als die knapp 3000 fotoaufnahmen
auswertete die ein ferngesteuertes
kamerasystem am tiefsee observatorium
des alfred-wegener-instituts dem
hausgarten in der östlichen framstraße
gemacht hatte wie in den anderen
europäischen gewässern hat die aw
meeresbiologin auf dem seeweg zwischen
grönland und spitzbergen hauptsächlich
kunststoffmüll gefunden beispielsweise
plastiktüten selbst im motiv der
tiefsten hausgarten station und dem mit
5.500 metern tiefsten punkt des
arktischen ozeans hatten die
wissenschaftler des
alfred-wegener-instituts schon im jahr
1999 kunststoff mehr gesichtet das
problem mit dem plastik ist also
wirklich nichts neues mit den entdeckten
mikroben könnte aber eine natürliche und
vielversprechende methode entdeckt
worden sein wie man das problem
zumindest in teilen in den griff
bekommen kann auch anders gibt es ein
riesiges müllproblem im weltall rund um
die erde
und dieser müll bedroht die raumfahrt
sehr spannendes video dafür einfach hier
klicken
lasst bitte einen daumen nach oben wenn
euch das video gefallen hat abonniert
den kanal kostenlos dafür einfach hier
klicken
und wie seht ihr das haltet ihr es für
effektiver zum beispiel beim einkaufen
auf eine plastiktüte zu verzichten und
an stattdessen zu einer leinentasche
zugreifen oder glaubt ihr an die arbeit
der mikroben lasst es uns in den
kommentaren disco
tieren und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran